أعلم أن بن ذكر أن
التأثير الاقتصادي لهذا كان محسوسًا بالتأكيد في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
وسنظل نشعر به في جميع أنحاء
العالم في الأسابيع المقبلة ،
هذه نقطة اختناق عالمية بحرية
في أفضل الأوقات ،
أخبار جيدة ولا شك بالنسبة للكثيرين  الأشخاص الذين
لديهم
إمدادات تحاول إيصالها عبر
العالم ،
أعني عندما تسد أحد
أكبر شريان التجارة في العالم
12 من التجارة العالمية تمر عبر تلك
القناة ، يمكنك فقط تخيل كيف
يتردد صداها في
جميع أنحاء العالم ونحن نتحدث
النفط والغاز كما تتوقع في تلك
المنطقة وكان هناك
نوع من النقص الحاد الذي رأيناه بالفعل
ولكن عليك أيضًا أن تنظر على
نطاق أوسع فأنت تعرف فقط منتجي المواد الخام
الذين يصنعون القهوة
لا يمكنك الحصول عليها  من إفريقيا أو آسيا
إلى أوروبا إلى صانعي المتاجر من
أثاث المواشي من ايكيا ، سمها ما شئت ، كانت
أكثر من 300
سفينة تصطف في طوابير على جانبي
القناة التي تم تقديمها على جانبي تلك
القناة
عالقة  لإعادة التوجيه ، قد
يستغرق الأمر ما يصل إلى 15 يومًا
للتنقل عبر جنوب إفريقيا وهو أمر
مكلف ، وهذا يكلف
الشركات ، ونحن نتحدث عن جميع
أنواع الشركات في جميع أنحاء العالم
بأموال حقيقية الآن هذه الأخبار التي ربما
تكون السفينة على متنها  الطريقة التي ربما
كان فيها تعويمًا ناجحًا هي
أخبار جيدة ونرى أن
روبن ينعكس بالفعل
على سبيل المثال في العقود الآجلة للنفط يمكنني أن
أخبرك أن خام برنت انخفض حاليًا بنسبة 2
بالوزن المنخفض بنسبة 2.4 في المائة ، وربما سنبدأ
في رؤية ذلك بالنسبة للبعض  من بين
السلع الأخرى كانت مخاوف بشأن
القهوة ،
فأنت تعلم أن القهوة الأوروبية من إفريقيا
وآسيا تمر عبر هذه القناة
، وقد انتشرت التأثيرات على نطاق واسع ،
وسيستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت بالطبع حتى لو كانت تلك
السفينة في طريقها ، فسوف يستغرق الأمر
وقتًا للحصول على كل  السفن إلى حيث
ينبغي أن تكون وجميع المنتجات التي
يحتاجون إليها للوصول